ah
[Music]
[Music]
look Simba everything the light touches
is our kingdom one day the Sun was set
on my time here and will rise with you
the new team
I'm gonna be the king of Pride Rock I
don't if he brings like you be brave
when I have to be
life's not fair is it my little friend I
must pick the throne run away Simba and
never return
remember who you are
you must take your place
in the circle of life Simba you have to
take your place as king
we need you
come home later Oh everyone calm down
we're here the backup has arrived
[Music]
sumo
you must remember who you are
the one true teeth
life's not fair
visit my little friend while some are
born to feast others spend their lives
in the dark
[Music]
begging for scraps
everything you see
exist together in a delicate balance
[Music]
while others assists for what they can
take a true king census for what he can
do
[Music]
run away Simba
never return
you must take your place
[Music]
and the circle of life
with Louisville
[Music]
everything the light touches is our
kingdom
but Aki's time is ruler rises and falls
like the Sun one day the Sun was set on
my time here
and will rise with you as the new king
remember
[Music]